Batman destroys the Justice League and
it's amazing check this out so in DC
Comics there's a story called Tower of
Babel where different members of the
Justice League all start finding
themselves being defeated in different
ways that the Martian Manhunter is set
on fire Aquaman is left into an area
with no water Wonder Woman's fighting an
invisible enemy that no one can see but
her come to find out all of these are
based on a series of protocols that
Batman had designed exclusively to
defeat every single member of the
Justice League and the protocols had
been attained by the Justice League
villain Raz al Ghul who had been using
them to defeat the entirety of the
Justice League team want to know the
worst thing that happens razlag will
realize is the only way to defeat Batman
is to dig up his parents Graves and then
drop their bodies into a vat of acid in
front of Batman it breaks them
psychologically and because of the
protocols the Justice League doesn't
trust him anymore make sure you guys
check the link in the comments for the
full video